In our research we've found that
humans go through a period of
change.
Right around the age of puberty.
Woooowwwww.
You guys are really doing some
ground breaking work here aren't
ya.
First they start being rude and
sarcastic.
Then they try to fit in.
By giving up the very quirks and
interests.
That make them who they are.
Next thing you know
They're all just dreamless
husks.
Stumbling blind toward the
grave.
Like a bunch of sad lonely
ghosts.
Jesus!
Look what would have happened to
your favorite cultural heroes.
If they'd given up on their
dreams.
You ever heard of Drizzy drake?
We started from the bottom.
Now where here.
Which is very alarming I might
add.
Oh God not the 6 man!
There's more.
♪ Hello ♪
Hi Yes, Um...
I'm calling to see if your are
satisfied.
with your current auto
insurance policy.
Jesus! turn that off.
Come on stop it.